Well, Muslims around the world have celebrated one of the biggest holidays on the Islamic calendar.
Eid al-Fitr begins with the new moon and marks the end of the holy month of Ramadan.
Despite heavy rain across much of Southern Asia,...
...people braved the wet to pack into local mosques like this one in Bangladesh.
By the grace of God, we have successfully performed the fasting during Ramadan.
Today, I've attended the first prayer session in this mosque,...
...and now we'll go meet with friends and relatives to exchange Eid greetings.
The celebration is a key milestone marking three days of feasting and joy after a month of discipline.
In India, the army even hosted an Iftar reception...
...with the hope of fostering harmony in India's troubled Kashmir region.
We're praying for peace, prosperity and brotherhood, and we must foster the spirit of brotherhood.
We must consider others' lives as precious as our own.
This is a message spread by Islam and whatever we do must be in the interest of the nation.
Millions are celebrating Eid across Pakistan,...
...though in Karachi, tight security measures are being imposed.
But there and in other areas, Pakistanis are determined to enjoy their days of celebration.
Eid is a festival for all Muslims and it is collective happiness.
Muslims around the world celebrate Eid with passion.
Muslims in Malaysia and Indonesia have also held their prayers,...
...with Malaysians practicing the custom of cleaning the graves of family members...
...in the hope of passing on piousness to the next generation.
Manny Maung, ABC News.